على بعد كم كان يقف الاعلاميون في كل مره
يجتمع خلالها الطرفان الاسرائيلي
واللبناني للتفاوض
في السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر كانت المره
الاخيره التي تعود فيها الى ساحه الناقوره
فضي فوق الترسيم وقع ومراسم التسلل
والتسليم حددت في واحده من اجمل بقعه
لبنان الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
في الوصول الى نقطه جغرافيه من
الاقتراب منها
فالجانب اللبناني حدد شروطا للقاء مع بلد
يقع تحت خانه العاده
توصلنا مع الممثل الجهه التي امنت
الترتيبات اللوجستيه للطرفين ليتبين ان
الوصول الى مكان الاتفاق مستحيل حتى وان
كان يقع ضمن نطاق اليونيفيل لكنه يعني
العبور بين الحدودين
تم اصطحابنا الى اقرب نقطه تطل على المكان
عبر طريق لا يسمح للمدنيين بعبوره
اراضي ان الشاسعه لا تزال محرمه على
اصحابها بعد اعوام من انتهاء الاحتلال
وصلنا الى نطاق اليونيف المئه و 31
يقول المتحدث باسمها ان خيمه نصبت في اسفل
البحر هنا لاستقبال اللبنانيين
والاسرائيليين والفريق المفاوض
فالعدد ما كان ليتسع داخل غرفه صغيره دخل
اللبنانيون من باب يطل على الجانب
اللبناني
والاسرائيليون دخلوا من الجانب الاخر
للحدود
التقطت بعد الصور لكنها لم توزع حتى اليوم
صور لم تجمع اللبنانيين مع الاسرائيليين
رغم وجودهم في المكان ذاته حتى ان الجانب
اللبناني علق على اصغر التفاصيل فرفض مثلا
ان تقدم مياه بماركات لبنانيه
للاسرائيليين لتستبدلها اليونيفيل بمياهن
ايطاليا
[موسيقى]
هو دائما امر ايجابي ومفيد لمهنتنا لانه
لا تزال هناك امور عائلقه الخط الازرق
الذي ترينا لا يزال يحتاج الى ترسيم
النهائي المهم ان هذا الاتفاق قد يفسح
المجال امام المشكلات التي لا تزال تنتظر
حلا من المهم ان نؤكد ايضا ان البلدين لا
يزلان في حاله حرب ونحن نامل ان نتوصل
الاتفاق دائما لوقف اطلاق النار نحن ايضا
لدينا مهمات بحريه لكن حمايه الحدود
البحريه ليست من واج عملنا يقتصر على منع
تهريب الاسلحه ونعمل على دعم الجيش
اللبناني حتى يصبح قادرا على القيام بكامل
المهمات دون دعمنا
خيمه التفاوض هي خط العوامات وهو خط بحري
حدودي اختلقته اسرائيل عام 2000 مع
الانسحاب من جنوب لبنان
وحاول التثبيته في الاتفاق الاخير لكن
لبنان رفض ذلك وبكيا نحو سبعه كيلو مترات
بالقرب من الشاطئ موضع خلاف حتى اشعار اخر
خاصه ان هذا الخط يكذب من حدود لبنان
البريه في حال تم الاتفاق عليها لاحقا
ودلانو فويس
[موسيقى]
وليس من واجب اليونيفيل مراقبته مهمتنا
مراقبه الخط الازرق على اليابسه فقط